right Let's Get Serious RTX 4070 is here
is this a graphics card that you should
be buying well this cost around about
580 pounds or 600 depending on where you
are in the world and in terms of
performance this is kind of similar to
something like an RTX 3080 except it
packs things like dlss 3.0 for better
frame rate in cyberpunk or anything that
supports these sort of features as well
as better Ray tracing support and I
guess with driver Updates this should
get better over time oh and we also have
more vram 12 gigabytes of this stuff
which is fantastic right well depending
on who you ask the rumor mill this
actually might not have enough of the
future so it's the 47c Dead on Arrival
or is this actually a really good
gravity scope that you should be
considering for your gaming PC it's
gonna be an interesting one so stay
tuned to learn absolutely everything you
need to know right after your short word
from this video sponsor alphasync is the
place to get the pre-built system of
your dreams without any knowledge on how
to build a PC alphasync gets you top
branded components at all budgets
lovingly put together right here in the
UK either choose a mastercrafted
alphasync specification or design yours
from scratch the choice is entirely up
to you get your game on today with that
link down below okay then let us begin
this video is actually going to be
focusing on the gigabyte gaming OC
though we will also be touching on the
founders Edition that we've already made
a video and build a belt you can find
this video in the top right corner of
your screen where we literally build
this computer and look at its
performance but let's get this under the
overhead and actually do ourselves a
little unboxing and you should be aware
that pricing is going to vary depending
on the SKU that you buy I think Nvidia
are actually being quite strict that all
aibs at least need or should have a card
that is going to cost the recommended
retail price of that 589 or that 600 but
cards like this can actually be a little
bit more expensive and indeed here we
have the gigabyte gaming OC it's
actually a very attractive card I think
this looks better than than the more
expensive 4070 TI and 48s because it is
actually a fair bit smaller and I guess
the design is just a bit more
well-rounded I mean when you compare it
against something like the ARs 4090
Master it looks absolutely ridiculous
this is not a small card yet compared to
this it really does look tiny this looks
to be a two and a half getting on for
three slot card whereas this is well
three to four that's pretty crazy but
this is a very extreme example and don't
forget they are of course going to need
a case that can actually accommodate
these not only for physical room but
also for cooling as well and if you want
to like front mount a radiator or
something then obviously you need a lot
of space but I think this card should
fit into most people's rigs already
you've got loads of cooling on this you
can see you've got this pass-through
design over here a full back plate that
looks and sounds like it's made out of
metal you've got a bile switch here for
your silent versus OC modes you've got
your 12 volt high power connection on
the top as well if you do go for the
more entry level cards you might find
one that has a single eight pin but both
the founders Edition and the overclock
cards will all have this new power
connection personally I think this is a
good thing it's a bit more future proof
one cable can make your rig look a whole
lot nicer but I understand some people
like what they have and they don't want
to have to upgrade or they were worried
about concerns about plugging in
properly but I think we're past that now
in terms of our outputs there's a pretty
standard and video Affair we've got one
HDMI 2.1 which is good for 4K 120 for
things like TVs or monitors then you've
got three display ports but they are
limited DisplayPort 1.4 not the 2.1 that
you'll find over on the AMD cards I
really don't think it matters with
something like this because we've not
got enough horsepower to drive them
anyway but if you want to listen to the
AMD marketing or you actually are going
to buy one of those monitors then you
should be aware that AMD is going to be
a better choice and of course we should
also mention that inside the Box you get
this wonderful thing which is your two
times eight pin to 1 12 or 16 pin
connection to actually get this card to
work so to be fair at the time of
filming there's loads of alternative
cables you can buy now that will look a
lot nicer I suppose or you can just buy
a new power supply that actually will
have the this connection as standard you
don't have to do that but if you want to
sort of go for something like this where
it's a Corsair cable it's braided and it
just looks a whole lot nicer I think the
overall effect is better than if you had
loads of eight pins personally let us
take our 4070 Foundation out so you can
actually see a full size comparison and
I mean the difference is pretty
noticeable if you put these two things
side by side I mean this is a two slot
GPU versus the two and a half and
obviously the length is very very
different so I would say this would be
great for like a smaller system
especially ITX but of course it's the
usual caveat that if you have something
like the NZXT H1 where this is sort of
going to blow straight into like a back
panel where you've got literally metal
behind the GPU then actually it's not
going to be the best choice because your
thermal performance isn't going to be
performing optimally but if you do have
a smaller rig in general than obviously
a small card assuming you can get around
this limitation is going to be better
but this should have better thermals and
better Acoustics but to be honest
spoiler alert for the rest of this video
this was already pretty much dead silent
in operation and didn't get hot because
it's so power efficient so I'm already
thinking I'm not convinced but I'd like
to be approved from let's stack all of
them up so you can see the difference
this is a 7900 XTX tough that is a lot
bigger and then this is a gaming OC 3080
TI this is actually quite a nice little
comparison because you can see I guess
it is actually quite similar to that and
it is ever so slightly smaller and I
would argue that the design is actually
a fair bit nicer as well I never really
liked this sort of edge bit that's been
cut out of this and the fans actually
look a bit nicer on this as well but
we'll wait and see until we get to
Performance whether this works but I'd
be very surprised if it doesn't so shall
we get this inside our rig do you know
what I'm asking you obviously we're
going to put it inside our rig this is
not a difficult bit is it let's grab
ourselves a monitor the PC Centric mouse
mat that you can buy and get ships today
I think it's two to three days shipping
but you can get this quick it's in stock
link down below pccentric dot store best
way to support the channel and then all
it needs is just a little
push
push my jokes don't work when they don't
work do they that was meant to be a dark
night reference but whatever you ruined
it now oh you're not funny neither are
you uh let's have a look well we've got
some sort of strobing going on with this
GPU at the moment you can obviously
change all of this in software that's
quite a cool look though I like that
maybe not all of the time but you've got
some RGB on the bottom of the card and
on the side where it says gigabyte we
are running this in its overclocked
modes but obviously you can change all
this around when you download the
software and this is the main thing
right if you do want to go for something
like this which is a more entry level
card entry level 580 pounds an entry
level card like this you can actually
whack on some software give it your own
fan curves but more importantly you can
increase the power limit increase the
clock speeds and you can even do this
with the GeForce experience overclocking
tool now so you can get more performance
out the box the way to think about them
is that they are Dynamic and they will
boost to actually get the most out of
the power that they have available but
also the cooling because they want to
hit a certain thermal limit and if they
have got there then you've got more
overclocking Headroom and obviously the
better calling on the card the more you
can push it that's the idea behind these
custom overclock cards because they have
better cooling you can push them further
but I would wager that both of these
cards are probably going to have really
good thermals to the point where you're
going to overclock it to its limit
anyway oh don't you just love a Windows
update they're always at the best
possible times let us begin with a game
I think a lot of people will be this GPU
for some Apex Legends and in terms of
the settings we're running this at 1440p
pretty much everything is maxed out
other than spots Shadow detail which is
set to very high and as we touch down on
the ground and net ourselves in purple
armor great start you can see we're
actually getting a pretty Monumental
frame rate actually around about 200 to
270 frames a second in Apex Legends and
that is impressive and I think this is
my I guess overarching view on this card
which is that this is still more
performance than anyone really needs
because if you are going to be playing
this at 1440p which I would wage on most
Gamers probably are anyway then why do
you actually need any more performance
than 200 frames a second at 1440p it's
nice to have all of the extras it's nice
to be able to turn Ray tracing on and
all of these dlss features they're
really useful but if you're going to be
playing multiplayer games your core
frame rate is probably the most
important thing and here if you're
getting over 200 frames a second at
pretty much Max settings that's probably
all you need but where things get
slightly more murky is with 4K
resolution because this is one of those
cards that a couple of years ago would
be marketed as a 4K card but now there's
even bigger ones that sort of marketed
as high 1440p but I still say this is
going to be a fine card for 4K gaming
regardless of whether you've got 4k
monitor or a 4K TV because as you can
see we're still getting over 100 frames
a second at 4K resolution and Apex
Legends isn't even a game that has dlss
or any sort of upscaling technique that
would actually allow you to not cheat
but to get extra frame rate by using
dlss technology AI upscaling oh we've
got trouble we got trouble
I've got no ammunition always good oh
blow I mean it is very hard to sort of
clean your neck and see this the point
being if you do want to play a
multiplayer game even at high
resolutions like 4K or maybe 340 by 1600
3440 by 1440 Ultra wide anything like
that 40 70 clearly is going to be an
excellent choice even over something
like the 4070 TI that has more
performance but costs quite a lot more
money but as I say multiplayer games are
quite easy what about literally the
hardest thing you can play on this PC
right now some cyberpunk with the new
overdrive path tracing updates that
doesn't sound exciting I don't know what
does I mean I could have solved that a
bit more the path tracing update once
again we'll start this at 1440p but in
terms of our options we will begin with
Ray tracing entirely off just the ultra
preset with frame generation off but
dlss sets to Quality and here we are
getting around about 80 to 90 frames a
second we've got dealer says frame
generation off that DLS says super
resolution set to Quality so this is
pretty much how you'd want to play the
game I think at 1440p if you didn't have
Ray tracing enabled and this is giving
you a good overexperience it's not as
crazy as you're going to get on a 40 90
or 4080 but obviously this is still
plenty of horsepower for a game like
this where things get a little bit
tricky though is if we enable the ray
tracing so let's do this but keep frame
generation off turn it on we'll enable
everything set it to ultra and this is
pretty much where we were with the 3080
like not a bad frame rate about 65 to 70
FPS which is still really good I mean
who doesn't want to play cyberpunk with
Ray tracing over 60 FPS I mean this is
actually better than I expected I
thought we'd see a little bit more of a
drop off we're losing what about 20
frames a second or so with Ray tracing
set to ultra so you can see how far
we've come actually with this latest
generation I'm a fan of this test
actually as I said I didn't expect that
however of course this being a 40 series
GPU you we can now go and enable dlss
frame generation go back into the game
and essentially this dynamically inserts
some frames with AI to give you an
overall smoother experience at the cost
of a little bit more latency compared to
dlss completely off you're getting about
the same sort of latency or actually a
little bit less but we're getting about
55 to 60 milliseconds of latency with
about 120 frames a second and this is
such a good way to play this game but of
course speaking of Cutting Edge
technology there is that path tracing
technology preview update and I do think
this is gonna make this PC sweat to the
point where I think the 4070 might be a
little bit underpowered but let's give
this a go I mean 1080p won't be a
problem but you're not buying a card
like this for 1080p I refuse to believe
that so let's go into Graphics scroll
all the way to the bottom path tracing
turn that on and I'm guessing about 50
frames a second oh oh oh yeah that
doesn't feel as good now that does not
feel as good now our frame rate is
actually fairly High we're getting about
76 frames a second or so but the latency
has jumped up to about 80 milliseconds
so it's nice that you can access this
but bear in mind this is an FPS game I
now do not like the way that this feels
that really does feel like we're getting
maybe 40 frames a second or so in terms
of like our true frame rate that's what
it feels like to me but I mean look how
cool that looks
it really is a massive Step Up versus
the normal Ray tracing it's a weird one
because everything just looks so much
more realistic and it's almost quite
difficult to explain because it's more
than the sum of its parts everything
adds up just to give you that really
realistic implementation I mean it's
still not perfect I mean give it like
five years and all of these Reflections
and things that you'll get under here
will be complete mirror images these are
clearly lower resolution than they would
be if you were sort of doing like I
guess crazy level of paths racing with
all of the detail on literally
everything but compared to it off it
looks absolutely fantastic it really
really does I mean it's nice as a little
demo just to walk around actually and
see what your GPU is capable of I mean
look at the reflections there it's it's
it's wild oh and of course what about
the noise levels the Acoustics the
temperatures well this is what it sounds
like
which actually is all the CPU Cooler
because this is one of the issues at the
moment if you go for like an Intel CPU
and you overclock it because this is
drawing like 200 watts and all of their
fans are sort of geared towards the CPU
the actual graphics card is quieter than
the rest of the system so clearly if you
do want to go for a really quiet system
the 4070 is a very decent choice but of
course in order to actually test The
Thermals we are going to have to put
this side panel on
no cheating I was gonna save this to the
end let's see if we can do some
overclocking now just to see if we can
get any practical Improvement to our
cyberpunk frame rate with all of the
bells and whistles enabled ah I was
gonna say this is 1440p still and it's
windowed but it's crashed I haven't even
done any overclocking yet so yes here we
are all the bells and whistles 1440p
windowed and we're currently getting
about 50 to 54 frames a second but if we
go and overclock this even further
really simple we just drank the power
limit all the way hit apply does that
make any difference at the moment no
maybe an extra frame but I think that's
placebo
so let's actually start fiddling with
our clocks let's add 100 well 121
apparently and our clock speed has
improved there we go
2940 but as you can see the frame rate
pretty much does stay exactly the same
push this up to 200. now we're at 3 000
megahertz but this is probably entering
borderline unstable territory
and we have gained a frame which is nice
we definitely have game the frame now
maybe two frames a second of extra
performance so there is some extra stuff
under the hood if you want to mess about
but I would wage it as soon as we go any
further than this we're probably
gonna say a crash so there is a little
bit of overclocking Headroom in this
probably about 150 megahertz s that you
can add but as I seem to say in every
single video that I'm doing on these
graphics cards at the moment they are
already pretty much at the limit that
there's not really that much extra you
can get out of them and if you can it's
not going to make any dramatic
difference to your game but it's always
worth having a slight fit of a bell and
I think we're fire up some Call of Duty
Warzone 2 and this time we're going to
start this at 4K resolution in terms of
quality we've got this set to ultra over
the textures turned up as high as
possible and you can see in terms of
vram utilization we're way under the 12
gigabytes so no problem there and in
terms of our frame rate bear in mind
we're running this at 4K resolution with
the dlss set to Quality we're actually
getting around about 100 FPS and I think
that is actually pretty impressive
because I think most people aren't
actually going to be running this at 4K
and if you were you'd probably lower
down a few settings to try and nail
about 120 so to be able to get 100 at
the ultra preset I think is actually
very very impressive but I think 1440p
is going to be more interesting for most
people and so here we go let's do this
again jumping out of the plane are we
gonna see a big difference immediately
it doesn't look drastic but it is
certainly a little bit higher I think
it's fair to say we're probably getting
an extra 15 to 20 frames a second or so
it is always going to vary depending on
sort of when and when you are in the
game but it's not actually as dramatic
as you might expect I'm not sure if this
is something that could be improved
maybe with like a driver update or
whether this just is the limitation at
the moment we're probably averaging
around about 115 frames a second rather
than about 90 as we were before so it is
an increase but it's still not going to
be that drastic 165 Hertz 1440p
experience that you might expect so I do
wonder if there is a little bit more in
the pipeline somewhere to come however
having said that it is actually worth
considering an AMD graphics card if you
pretty much exclusively play Warzone
because for some reason those cards
really seem to favor performance in that
game and you tend to get better levels
whether relatively to Team Green you see
all of this in the benchmarks that we've
shown in just a second but something
like a 6900 XT on the used Market or
maybe even a new 6950 XT the prices of
these are actually getting somewhat
similar especially to this overclocked
version of the 4070s so that is worth
considering if you pretty much just
played war zone but I think you need to
see the big picture I think you need to
see some numbers and I'm not the guy to
show you that unfortunately I never have
been I never will instead I need to hand
you over to the one the only benchmarkus
hello everybody how are we doing this is
benchmarkers and let's jump straight
into the numbers and starting off with
the 4070 itself I would argue that the
performance of this is actually pretty
good for the most part it's only about
16 FPS off the 4070 TI but obviously it
is much much cheaper even at 4K it
pretty much handles every game other
than cyberpunk over 60fps so if you are
looking to maybe get a 4K TV or Monitor
and you're happy to turn the settings in
in some games this is actually going to
be a perfect choice for you yes 12
gigabytes of vram isn't as much as
you'll find on AMD but we didn't really
run into any issues ourselves from
running this but in the future this
might change the big win really for the
4070 versus the 3080 that it shares
pretty much most of its performance with
is when it comes to dlss frame
generation or anything really where
we're running Ray tracing because you
will see better results there so if you
are looking for this sort of Ray tracing
cards Nvidia pretty much has it locked
down you should go Team Green swapping
out the resolution for 1440p and this is
definitely a GPU that is a lot more at
home yes you're still not going to hit a
minimum of 100 FPS in every single title
but actually for the most part we're
pretty much seeing averages of 100 FPS
or more in everything other than
cyberpunk with frame generation disabled
so I'd argue that's actually pretty
impressive especially given how
intensive cyberpunk can be interestingly
we do start to see a bit of an L when it
comes to Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2
though as at 1440p this card is actually
getting beaten by the RX 6700 XT an
older generation card that could be
found for less money than this but
otherwise the numbers pretty much line
up where you'd expect them to be the
only exception to this is actually the
gigabyte 4070 itself as as you can see
it's essentially indistinguishable from
the founders Edition and again assuming
you can buy them for the prices that
they're set at the rrps then clearly the
gigabyte card just offers worse value
for money than the founders and I can't
really see a reason to go for this
gigabyte one unless you're wanting to do
loads more overclocking yourself but you
could probably do this with the founders
or if the pricing availability
essentially makes the gigabyte a more
attractive option if there's like 10 20
pounds in it it doesn't really matter
but all the time there is a significant
price difference between the founders
and the gigabyte cards then the founders
pretty much makes a lot more sense in my
opinion I mean to properly illustrate
this have a closer look at our cost per
frame analysis while the 470 itself does
actually offer pretty good value
compared to the other new cards that
have been released this year that
doesn't necessarily make it a fantastic
purchase if you're paying a load more
money for an over clocked version that
just doesn't really give you any extra
performance in fact the 7900 XT now
actually slips between the 40 70
gigabyte and the 4070 Founders so bear
this in mind that's again not to say you
shouldn't buy this one just don't
overspend for a car but it's not
necessarily going to give you more
performance something that is absolutely
fantastic with the 4070 though is power
consumption and I guess performance per
watt because we're only getting around
about 200 Watts or so max consumes what
we're actually doing these tests which
is very very impressive bear in mind the
4090 gets 415 Watts pretty insane and in
terms of performance per watt you can
see you're getting a lot better
performance value with the 4070 compared
to pretty much any other card at all so
long term this is actually going to cost
you less to run than pretty much all the
other cards we have tested though with
newer cards coming I guess in a few
months time things like the 4 to 60 40
60 TI chances are these will probably
use even less and so then there you are
all the benchmarks I think you would
ever need what do you
I mean clearly it is the best card of
the generation when it comes to priced
performance but I still can't help but
think that this should really be a
little bit lower like all of the stacks
should cost less but unfortunately it
doesn't and we are at this sort of
Crossroads when I would say I do
recommend the 4070 overall because you
are still getting the performance that
most people need I think it's only
really Warzone that was a little bit
lower than I'd like everything else has
actually been quite impressive it can do
the cyberpunk ray tracing path tracing
update all of this stuff is a very
capable GPU but I do think it's probably
worth waiting a little bit just to see
what AMD do how they counter and whether
they can actually start a little bit of
a pricing War because while it didn't
happen with the 4080 I think that is a
bit disappointing there's no reason that
it can't happen with this as long as the
stock is available there isn't all of
this scalping going on then I think we
are in a good position for PC gaming to
get cheaper but I think the 4070 is a
very clear visual indicator that the
cost of PC gaming at the moment is
definitely at an all-time high really
and that in itself is disappointing but
you should always buy based on the
Benchmark should always buy based on
what you're going to use it for and
overall the 4070 definitely is worth
buying and it is the best 40 series card
I think this with the LSS 3.0 is finally
going to enable Ray tracing for the
masses which is great but how many
people care about Ray tracing over all
of the other things probably not that
many but fortunately the performance of
this is good enough to back it up
especially in things like Apex Legends
however having said all of this this
particular model the gigabyte gaming OC
is great but it is just too expensive
because you're looking at about 60 to 70
pounds more when it comes to Raw RRP for
a card that doesn't really give you any
extra performance I mean yes The
Thermals might be slightly better you've
got more mass I suppose more air that
you can properly move but in reality the
Fan's Edition is absolutely fine and is
pretty much very similar when it comes
to acoustic levels and if you're looking
at maybe like one frame a second more
I'm not really sure that's enough to
warrant the extra price but I think
realistically depending on when you're
watching this the prices are all going
to sort of merge and they will get quite
similar so I'm not going to say you
shouldn't buy this one because it is a
very good GPU but if you have the choice
between an entry level one something
like an eagle from gigabyte or a
Founder's Edition or anything really
like that that doesn't have the same
cooling performance but actually offers
the same sort of experience then I think
you should go for that and save yourself
some money but let me know your thoughts
on this down in the comment section
Below have you enjoyed this video have
you enjoyed the performance do you think
the pricing is fair or do you agree with
me that it probably should be a little
bit less than the whole situation with
gpus is still a bit of a mess let me
know down in the comment section below
but smash the like button if you've
enjoyed this get yourself subscribes and
if you do want to check out current
pricing on this particular GPU or
anything else featured in this video you
can find that link down below with my
Amazon affiliate links and while you're
down there be sure to check out
alphasync alphasync brings you a
worry-free PC gaming experience with a
huge range of custom built gaming PCs
with a 4.8 rating on trustpilot and free
next day delivery available on selected
builds why not let alphasync take all of
the stress out of PC gaming get started
today with a link down below thank you
so much for watching this video I'll
catch you in the next one
[Music]
foreign